wir sprechen jetzt mit einem der
profiliertesten virologen professor
hendrik steg den ganzen tag konnten die
zuschauer uns über whatsapp übers netapp
ihre sorgen ihre fragen zu schicken und
wir hoffen einige dieser fragen zu
beantworten herzlich willkommen herr
professor steht dazu und wir wollen
direkt mit der ersten frage beginn ist
die chance groß dass man steht am corona
virus nein also die chance ist wirklich
nicht groß am groner virus zu versterben
da hat sich vielleicht heute der chef
oder der leiter des robert koch
instituts seien wenig unglücklich
ausgedrückt
generell sehen wir in china und das kann
man auch auf europa übertragen eine eine
sterblichkeitsrate von ungefähr zwei
prozent 2,2 man muss das ein bisschen
relativieren dahingehend dass wir wissen
dass ungefähr 80 prozent wenn ich sogar
85 prozent der infizierten eine sehr
milde symptomatik haben und dass man
vielleicht viele gar nicht getestet hat
bisher ob sie vielleicht corona virus
träger sind und das gar nicht
mitbekommen haben bisher
daher sind es vor allem die älteren
menschen also die die über 70 jahre alt
sind und die auch bestimmte
vorerkrankungen haben zum beispiel eine
herzerkrankung haben die eine
lungenerkrankung haben das sind die die
eigentlich bisher am corona beer es
meistens verstorben sind
jeder krankheitsverlauf und eine geringe
sterberate das sind ja zumindest in
diesen zeiten der verunsicherung
beruhigende nachrichten lassen sie uns
zu der nächsten frage eines zuschauers
kommen oder leidet an einer
autoimmunerkrankung und ich bin sehr
besorgt
ich wollte fragen neben den üblichen
schutzmaßnahmen zum beispiel sich die
hände zu waschen und sich die hände zu
desinfizieren abstand halten zu leuten
die husten und niesen
was würden sie noch empfehlen kann sie
sorglos zu haus gehen oder muss ich
schon angst haben sich irgendwie
anzustecken
da der virus ja an oberflächen haften
bleibt
ja das ist natürlich eine gute frage
da haben auch viele die angst die er da
vielleicht auch ein asthma haben oder
doch eine krebserkrankung dass das sind
ja schon auch beschreibungen von
vorerkrankungen wo vielleicht so ein
virus mal gefährlicher werden kann
generell gilt erstmal da auch eine
rücksprache mit seinem hausarzt zu
halten und zu sehen welche maßnahmen man
für den speziellen pfeil noch treffen
kann
das ist gerade für solche personen
ratsam
zweitens ist für solche personen im
moment ratsam einfach größere
menschenansammlungen zu meiden wenn man
und das gilt nicht nur für das corona
virus das gilt auch für die grippe dass
man eben in zeiten wo um das eigentlich
nun system stark geschwächtes durch eine
autoimmunerkrankung dass man dann
versucht auch die infektions
wahrscheinlichkeit zu unterdrücken indem
man im menschenansammlungen und oder
auch vor einem wo man in dichten räumen
zusammen ist sowas dann vermeidet ja
also besonders betroffene die
vorerkrankungen haben sollten besonders
auf sich aufpassen
nun kommen wir zu einer weiteren frage
was müssen wir machen
gut wenn man infiziert ist hängt es ein
bisschen davon ab was für eine
symptomatik man hat wenn man nur eine
leichte symptomatik hat also sprich
einen typischen grippalen infekt mit
husten abgeschlagenheit und vielleicht
auch fieber aber man eigentlich sonst
nicht unbedingt sehr krank ist dann
reicht das zuhause zu bleiben sich
auszukurieren
man muss deswegen nicht in die
notaufnahme aber wenn man
nachgewiesenermaßen infiziert ist dann
und sollte man auch wieder daten mit dem
rücksprache mit dem hausarzt überlegen
ob es sinnvoll wäre dann keine zeit in
auf in isolation zu gehen entweder zu
hause oder im kranken
wenn die symptomatik sehr schwer ist
wenn man eine schwere lungenentzündung
hat also die atemwege sehr betroffen
sind hohes fieber und man sowieso in so
einem fall in eine notaufnahme gehen
würde und zum arzt dann sollte man auch
zur notaufnahme gehen denn dann muss man
sich darauf einstellen dass hier auch
eine stationäre aufnahme notwendig wäre
wichtig hier sicherlich auch dass nicht
jeder der ein gewisser erkältung oder
grippe symptome zeigt sofort sich in ein
volles wartezimmer setzt und damit
andere menschen in gefahr bringt nun
kommen wir zu der letzten frage meine
frage bezüglich den krone virus werde
was passiert im körper des infizierten
also das weiß man natürlich nur zum teil
bisher aber wir wissen von dem coro
navis oder dem neuen corona virus jetzt
dass es sich sehr gut in den oberen
rachen gegen anreichert und dort auch
vermehrt also man muss sich das so
vorstellen das virus dockt an die
schleimhautzellen an repliziert und
repliziert und zerstört dabei quasi die
ratenzahlung das macht diese information
die reizung die immunzellen kommen rein
versuchen dagegen anzukommen und dadurch
dass es aber im oberen rachenbereich ist
ist die problematik dass eine
übertragung sehr leicht stattfinden kann
indem man leute an hustet oder dadurch
an liest und daher ist es gerade im
moment so wichtig hier auch selber drauf
zu achten wenn man infiziert wäre dann
eine gute husten niesen husten und
niesen die kette zu haben und den
anderen nicht ins gesichts und niesen
sondern eher und auch nicht in die hand
sondern in die ellbogen oder zur seite